let's talk about the much anticipated
debate last night between the current
Republican Georgia Governor Brian Kemp
and the Democratic Challenger Stacy
Abrams Stacy Abrams is genuinely
brilliant she's really good at debates
she actually knows things about so many
different issues and it came through in
the debate but Brian Kemp just couldn't
resist doing the angry black woman
routine
check out what he had to say this is
really like a good old boy tired debate
strategy the black woman is upset and
she's mad and she's angry I know Miss
Abrams is upset and mad
and that knowing tilt of the head from
Stacy Abrams now I have to tell you
she was no more mad than anybody else on
the stage in fact the libertarian guy uh
was Furious that they wouldn't take his
idea seriously because they're crazy
ideas
um or let him speak as much as much as
he wanted to and we're going to get to
that in a moment but this entire you're
mad and upset she was no more mad and
upset than anybody else and it was just
another one of these pathetic racially
based tropes now she did really really
well
um at one point when uh she was asked
something along the rights along the
lines of what's the biggest danger
facing Georgia she said the biggest
danger is the guy who's currently the
governor this is a governor who's for
the last four years has beat his chest
but delivered very little for most
Georgians he has weakened gun laws and
flooded our streets he has weakened our
privacy rights and our and women's
rights he has denied women the access to
reproductive care the most dangerous
thing facing Georgia is four more years
of Brian Kemp we need a governor who
actually understands the math and the
morality yeah this is a governor she um
I mean listen it's very common right now
that candidates don't know anything like
when you ask Mehmet Oz hey can you um
like talk about health care policy and
how you would bridge the gap between a
and b and what do you think is the best
way to get care but to keep you you know
he'll just go with one of those weird
rants like the one he did about you know
send people to like a medical tent and
just give him like a five minute exam or
something like he doesn't really
understand things at a policy level
there's a total lack of empathy there's
a total lack of pragmatism as to how you
actually get bills passed and and get
money for the things you need to do
Stacey Abrams knows so much like she is
Head and Shoulders above so many of the
people that are running right now and
she's stuck in this insane situation
with a lot of cuckoo Georgia voters many
totally sensible Georgia voters as well
and a governor who goes oh she's angry
she's mad and she's angry and she really
knows about so many different things
here's another clip where Brian Kemp oh
by the way this is another theme in a
lot of the debates that we've been
covering and we've covered now must be
about 10 or so just in the in the last
few weeks the Republican will just lie
about what the law is or lie about their
record they'll just completely make it
up Brian Kemp did a lot of that last
night where he said listen we have a
full background check law for firearms
purchases in Georgia every single
purchase requires a background check and
of course that's not true there's the
private sale loophole there's the Gun
Show loophole and Stacy Abrams can do
nothing to prevent herself from
interrupting understandably so because
Kemp just can't stop lying or won't on
well there there's a background check
there's a federal background check on
every individual that buys a firearm in
the United States of America shouldn't
exist either well the point that's not
true I understand the point you're
making but the point is when you buy a
firearm you get a background check none
of the laws Mr Kemp if you purchased the
weapon in Georgia through a gun sale or
a private sale
she's completely correct of course but
this this is the widely known Gun Show
loophole private sale you know family
family sale loophole and the libertarian
guy in the middle who is trying to talk
over everybody
he says we shouldn't have any background
checks whatsoever I guess I mean he by
the way the libertarian during
yesterday's debate said uh get rid of
um gun safety regulations uh get rid of
Fiat money get rid of public education
give I can't even remember the full list
of what he said then he was Furious no
one was taking him seriously so uh Kelly
Abram Stacy Abrams doing everything she
could here to try to inject some truth
and reality into the conversation uh one
other moment that I will play for you
um a moment about a plans where uh Brian
Kemp took this sort of this is kind of
like a an escape hatch to any issue you
don't really want to deal with is to say
let's study that issue Stacy Abrams was
having none of it when it came to
helping minority-owned businesses a lot
of Georgians including African Americans
and other minorities cannot go to work
if their kids are not in the classroom
we have the lowest unemployment rate in
the country for African-American we also
were named uh the top we're in the top
ten of the states for black
entrepreneurship uh in the state of
Georgia so our economy is incredible and
we will continue to work with all of
those entrepreneurs in the days ahead
and working class Georgians because we
are the ones that have been fighting for
you when Miss Abrams was not we were
giving tax refunds we were doing tax
cuts we were suspending the gas tax to
help you deal with 40-year high
inflation when she was criticizing us
Stacey Abrams 32nd rebuttal I would
point out that Mr Kemp did not address
the needs of purchasing and contracts
for black and brown owned businesses
which is what he's refused to do for the
last 16 years we know that 10.9 billion
dollars has been delivered to the state
of Georgia through two recent acts at
the Congressional level and Brian Kemp
does not have a plan for making certain
that people of color have access to
those contracts access to purchasing it
was only in July of this year that he
finally acknowledged that there might be
a problem he has said that when need to
study it I would tell him just cheat off
of my paper I know the answer we need a
governor who actually believes in equity
racial Equity economic equity in the
state of Georgia and I will deliver so
listen here's the bottom line with this
race unfortunately uh uh Stacy Abrams I
keep mistaking Kemp and saying Kelly
Abrams which is not what I mean to say
Stacy Abrams is falling further and
further behind uh Brian Kemp and much of
this is happening
I believe because there have actually
not been really clear statements made
about what is at stake if these
Republicans win in November now Stacey
Abrams has made it clear
but the bigger picture we have to zoom
out and really think about all of these
races and the supplies in Pennsylvania
the supplies in Florida Arizona Georgia
really everywhere you know we can have
substantive policy debates about what
should the level of Taxation be or as
far as States go property taxes or some
of these other policy things there is a
movement
Nationwide right now from the Republican
Party
wherein their focus is how can we just
take more and more control of all of the
basic systems on which we depend voting
infrastructure education
Torpedoes some of them deliberately in
order to reinforce our control it's
insanely authoritarian and that big
picture I don't think is being
effectively enough communicated to
voters now okay that that's sort of a
bigger rant in terms of the numbers uh
Stacy Abrams five and a half points
behind Brian Kemp on average right now
it's it's not Out Of Reach necessarily
but let's be honest that two and a half
weeks to make up five and a half points
in a gubernatorial race in a sort of
reddish leading state which sometimes
votes for a Democratic president and
right now has two Democratic senators I
should mention
um is a is something that has to be
overcome now one last thought on last
night's debate there was this
libertarian guy who was also part of the
debate and
on the one hand I I've mixed feelings as
to what position I should take on this
because on the one hand I want third
parties I hate the two-party duopoly we
need more voices it debates if you
qualify for the debate you should be
there and get as much time to speak as
everybody else at the same time
we know the guy has no shot he was a
complete lunatic anti-vaxx
anti-everything
and he's not going to be the next
Governor so there was also time wasted
from really forcing Brian Kemp to have
to engage with Stacey Abrams on the
issues
and so I I have sort of mixed feelings
about the participation of the
libertarian guy but needless to say
Stacey Abrams super smart did an
incredibly good job will it make a
difference we'll have to wait and see
huge numbers of people report that CBD
has a calming effect that can help with
anxiety stress insomnia and our sponsor
feels is a premium CBD designed to help
you feel your best delivered right to
your door you just place a few drops of
feels under your tongue CBD can also be
a safe method for relieving minor aches
and pains without side effects the thing
to remember about CBD is that finding
the right dose is important and feels
even has experts on call to help you
with that over the phone if you need a
dose of Chill on the go you've got the
feels CBD infused mints and you'll get
fresh breath hard to complain about that
and with a feels monthly membership CBD
is simply a breeze you save money on
every order you can pause or cancel at
any time become a member today and get
50 off your first order with free
shipping when you go to feels.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below